ok
[Musique]
non
bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir paris
enfin paris j'ai cru que c'était paris
vienne bruxelles comme l'a expliqué moi
j'ai vraiment cru que c'était paris dont
j'avais prévu mon billet train jusqu'à
la gare du nord etc
j'avais pas qu'il fallait encore prendre
l'avion n'aurait pas pris mon passeport
la paperie de casse croûte
j'avais pas pris ma burqa lorsque j'ai
vu que dans le quartier avait beaucoup
de shows kotov c'est pour ça je me
présente je m'appelle kaoutar mes amis
m'appellent chaos parce que c'est plus
court c'est plus facile à retenir et
puis ça veut dire vaches en anglais je
sais exactement ce que vous êtes en
train de vous dire mais quel lien
pourrait-il y avoir entre cette
délicieuse créature est une vache aucun
et celui qui ose pense l inverse
attention parce que tu as de molenbeek
en même temps on ne prenait pas trop de
risques alors je m'appelle kaoutar
kaouther ça veut dire abondance en arabe
ces gens comprennent arabe ici dans
cette wii une wii je suis là donc ça
veut dire abondance
effectivement j'ai la chance
d'expérimenter l'abondance chaque jour
de ma vie qu'un abondance de factures
abondance de rupture abondance de
courbure
non mais ça c'est pas grave c'est j'ai
appris à l'accepter comme dirait un
grand philosophe belge on a un seul
philosophe en belgique il était vivre
aux états unis
tu sais le principe pas être were hockey
[Applaudissements]
inspiré tout symptôme incorporait sa
norme cocaïnomane hommes ce qui veut
dire un esprit sain dans un corps sain
avec des petits ça ça c'est moi ouais
parce que je sais pas si vous voyez
quand vous regardez mon corps j'ai été
livré avec un corps à gros seins s'en
laissa donc j'en profite ce soir je sais
que la presse présente donc s'il vous
plaît je transmet un message si on
retrouve mes seins j'aimerais bien les
avoir comme ça fait 25 ans que les
attend pour rigoler mais c'est horrible
je suis je suis d'une plate s à l'école
on m'appelle platon
non c'est un truc de fou c'est dur de
vivre avec le sms le sms le syndrome des
micro st
dans c'est super dur en plus comme j'ai
pas vraiment une corpulence qui a adapté
imaginez un peu l'ascenseur émotionnel
pour les mecs que j'ai connu les pauvres
tu vois c'est un peu comme si tu vois
une grosse carrosserie sachez pas moins
de 4 4 tu montes a atterri ensuite mot
violence et des pédales à vélo
supercherie non non c'est pas bien à
papa faire des trucs comme ça ce qui est
bien c'est qu'on m'indique awtar
t'inquiète pas le jour où tu auras des
enfants tant à dessein j'en ai trois
j'ai passé un marché pour vous les
filles il ya des moments dans la salle
bref c'est un marché pour vous oui pour
toi avez chacun son terme a alors c'est
super je sais pas si vous avez remarqué
les filles cars est enceinte
il ya toujours une espèce de potiche
dans votre entourage qui a un ventre
super plein qui a pas d'enfants qui en
aura jamais cette [__] elle n'aura
jamais d'enfant elle vient vous caresser
le ventre tu vois comme ça et on va les
venue elle me fait ouais c'est trop
mignon tu as une préférence
je dirais 95d c'est bien après ce j'ai
un bonnet c je vais pas faire ma chiante
un non non moi du moment que ils sont en
bonne santé pas de kiss pas de fibromes
bien réguliers bien faire bien haut
je m'engage à les aimer de manière
inconditionnelle non mais écoutez ça n'a
pas marché avec trois enfants
je me suis dit peut-être que j'aurais dû
persévérer parce que quand je regarde ma
mère elle en a eu sept et chez elle ça
bien foisonner fonctionner ma mère c'est
un peu l'inversé de moi moi je suis un
triangle sur base ma mère c'est un peu
le triangle sur pointes
c'est à dire quand elle se met devant
moi un ou deux en forme l'étoile de
david g j'ai jamais fait part de cette
comparaison à ma mère sinon je ne serais
pas là pour vous l'expliquer non mais
c'est vrai ma mère elle a vraiment eu
sept enfants je suis la 7e elle a eu six
garçons avant moi donc en toute logique
comme elle a eu six garçons elle voulait
plus d'enfants ok donc voila mais bon je
suis quand même arrivé tu va déterminer
mais c'est vrai que je me suis posé la
question et il y aura même un commis cet
enfant est ce qu'elle voulait vraiment
en avoir sept combien est-ce que ma mère
voulait d'enfants je suis posé cette
question parce que comme la bouilloire
la pénitence à cet enfant il faut être
motivé donc j'étais d'avoir un jour ma
mère je me posais la question je dis
maman à la base tu voulais combien
d'enfants
elle m'a répondu ah merde je verrai
jamais marre ça écoute moi bien ma
sphère budget il a dit quand tu penses
non c'était doit dérober et moi j'ai
pensé cette fois non à l'ue et la 17e
fois oui
je voulais comme ça se faisait tous
venus car sa co star ça veut dire la
rage gens vous étiez vraiment des
spermatozoïdes
tu vois qu'ils n'ont pas lâché la faire
jeudi j'ai fait je répondu maman tu en
train de me dire qu'à aucun moment tu
n'as rien senti cet élan intérieur
intrinsèque puissant qui te pousse vers
ce désir irrépressible de devenir mère
en fait je crois pas en faire ce qu raté
plateau j'ai répondu à ta question avait
il faut pas pousser bobonne dans
l'attenté 1
donc voilà elle voulait zorro enfants
c'est à dire que mathématiquement au
premier enfant sa motivation était 2 0
et je suis la 7e je vous laisse faire un
peu le calcul
donc je suis arrivé dans ces conditions
très heureuse n'est ce pas et je pense
que c'est pour ça qu'elle m'a donné ce
prénom
kaoutar savaient pas très physique et ou
tard se termine en art comme edgar
edouard connard que des attributs
typiquement masculin on est bien
d'accord et c'est je crois que ce qui
m'a donné aussi ce côté un petit peu
vous savez androgyne mi femme mi jin
mais je tiens à rassurer l'audience de
ce soir je suis 100% hétérosexuels
célibataire souple et disponible
non mais c'est vrai c'est pas évident je
suis vraiment célibataire parce qu'à
chaque fois que j'étais avec un mec en
fait il avait toujours quelque chose à
dire si c'était pas le poids c'était la
tenue vestimentaire
mon dernier mais qui me disait chéri
maigri pas trop les os et pour les
chiens et j'ai répondu ça tombe bien
parce que d'aussi lourds et me souviens
du connu que ça des chiens non je
plaisante messieurs j'ai pas connu que
des chiens
j'ai connu des ports aussi les ports de
plaisance les ports de plaisance n'est
pas avec des grosses péniche dit [__]
d'amarrage des ports quoi
non mais sérieux franchement c'est
difficile
moi personnellement j'ai eu difficile à
les satisfaire ou alors c'était si ce
n'est pas le point fait effectivement
c'était la tenue vestimentaire qui leur
convenait pas et la dernière fois que
j'étais avec un mec qui m'a dit chéri ce
soir on sort fait un effort sétois belle
traduction au repos tu es moche
donc ce soir là j'ai fait un effort
jamais une petite jupe des petits
escarpins un petit décolleté affriolant
même si bon chez moi on a bien compris
que c'est pas de quoi ça priolet je suis
arrivé tout content comme ça il m'a dit
tu vas sortir comme ça on dirait une
[__] tu dis ok tu vois je reconnais même
changé je veux dire wade me mettre un
truc tranquille j'ai mis un jogging
baskets je suis revenu il m'a dit de
tenir comme ça vous dirait mon cousin
hamid
ok tu vois je suis on va faire simple et
efficace jean fils de là-bas sur nîmes
du temps à sortir comme ça on dirait
votre femme et d'un puis tu sais quoi
je suis retourné j'ai trouvé tout ce qui
touche tout ce qui me passait sous la
main une chemise en velours un soutien
gorge par dessus un char du real madrid
et bas résille chose est adidas des
babouches suis revenu il m'a dit je suis
comme ça on dirait votre famille
d'accueil et de faire la [__]
j'ai dit tu sais quoi chérie je sors pas
ce soir je reste à la maison je regarde
la télévision
je suis resté chez moi j'ai allumé la
télé devinez ce que c'était les rênes du
shopping tout le monde connaît oui rien
qui me laisse pas c'est dommage
la partie qui va suivre va pas trop vous
intéresser les rênes du shopping c'est
christina cristina cordula ya qu elle
manie fight ya que l c'est la reine les
autres c'était valais on est bien
d'accord déjà vu cette dame comment il
parle aux gens elle te détruit des
personnalités elle te sable des morales
mais avec son grand sourire elle son
petit accent brésilien ses sympathies
marc cherry cette fois là il y avait une
petite participantes elles étaient
comment vous dire elle était comme au
niveau de mes cuisses mais partout donc
elle était un peu globalement sphérique
christina l'a vu à le faire aïe aïe aïe
mon chéri ce au point de tout de paris
nice barcelone n'a aucun secret pour 1h
tiens au sein d une boule du rôle à ma
chérie leblanc sur toi ça va pas sa
tasse à fait patiner il ya du volume en
bar ya du volume
non ma chérie ça hein pas du tout sauf
mon fils à la vanille 1
j'adore avec le café de temps à autre un
pas tous les jours sinon je deviens
comme toi hors marché ne t'inquiète pas
on a tout prévu
bourse aux disques plein format
jardinier une équipe au top qui va faire
du boudin que tu es une reine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
ben bien qu'à otages temps presse et les
interviews la table bien garnie massée
petit déplacement valait kun franchement
super sympa vous êtes au top je regrette
pas d'avoir fait quatre heures de route
[Applaudissements]
t'as pas l'air convaincu juin jeudi
c'était bien politique ce tarif est la
pire que moi quand j'étais enfant vous
êtes au top j'ai bien fait prendre le
rer a c'est quoi ton accrédités alors
ben moi je joue deviner ou en belgique
donc voilà je fais partie d'un collectif
qui tapait le collectif you rire il ya
plein d'humoristes super sympa donc je
vous invite à découvrir la page facebook
you rire comme ça s'entend thierry et
voilà donc je fais des scènes j'en ai eu
ici vendredi j'en ai encore une samedi
voilà mourir collectif kaoutar les
errants à bruxelles aussi on peut te
voir à bruxelles menthe ou t'es sur la
page du collectif 1 d'accords conclus à
m'écouter on peut encore applaudir
kaoutar s'il vous plaît merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tant que big n
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]